voilà c'était l'opinion glané
aujourd'hui dans saint girons vous avez
entendu avec moi chantal hébert chef
david michels et au gie bonsoir mon nom
soit alors bon c'est une nouvelle
gigantesque dans la campagne électorale
depuis hier on ne parle à peu près que
de ça premier tour de table sur l'effet
à court terme et à moyen terme sur la
campagne parlons de ça chantal d'abord
ça sa capture l'imagination de toute
évidence c'est un gros coup je suis pas
certaine que ça allait un tacle de
rehausser de blasons économique autant
que ce que le pq a dit ian santiago
candidats économique qui me semble que
ça plus d'impact sur le débat sur la
souveraineté que sur l'image économique
du parti québécois et je suis assez
curieuse de voir quelle place ça va
aménager la souveraineté dans
l'argumentaire de madame marois qui
avait pas l'air particulièrement
disposés en parle qu'on en parle
beaucoup depuis trois jours d'accès
c'est quelqu'un qui est plus importante
on a des voix référendaire s'il a lieu
qui est important pour ce débat
électoral si dans ce débat électoral si
justement il va forcer de parler d'une
part de souveraineté un peu plus que le
pq ne l'aurait voulu
puis d'autre part il ya des gens qui
disent basse est amené à fait quand on
parle de l'es14 la koutla puis 2 en 2000
et 2009 54 % des jours perdus par lock
out au québec on était dans les
entreprises où monsieur péladeau il y à
déjà d'une aile plus progressistes du
vécu de bons sentiments à l'aise avec ça
c'est certain
est-ce qu'ils vont déménager ça c'est
une autre histoire mais
c'est clair que c'est un énorme moi je
pense qu'il va y avoir des gens qui vont
qui vont quitter qui vont être fâchés
mais je pense que ça va être beaucoup
moins important que les gens qui vont
aller chercher grâce à monsieur péladeau
et ceux qui vont quitter vont
probablement à montréal et ça coûtera
pas grand chose au pq en termes de
sièges tandis qu'ils peuvent aller
chercher beaucoup de cas qui est dans
des comptes est important pour le pq en
particulier dans la région de québec
mais aussi dans 4 5 0 alors pour ce qui
est de l'élection qui vient je pense que
c'est au total un très bon coup pour le
référendum si on se rend jusque là je
lisais quelqu'un dans de l'eau qui dit
aujourd'hui que ça pourrait avoir qui
pourrait jouer le même rôle que lucien
bouchard en 1995
je pense que la comparaison est bonne
mais que dans un certain sens ils
pourraient encore plus important dans la
mesure où monsieur bouchard on l'a vu il
faisait vibrer nos tripes de québécois
tout le monde mais il était incapable de
rassurer ceux qui ont peur des
conséquences économiques d'un oui alors
que monsieur péladeau pourrait leur dire
écoutez moi les affaires je connaisse
je vous garantis on est capable ça va
être payant alors ils voient qu'il
peuvent être tracés ceux qui diraient
ceux chantal un mot sur le reste qu'un
ami chilien en parler saül effet on se
réintéresse rapidement au québec on
s'était déjà qu'il ya intéressé à cause
des sondages qui donnaient un pq
imaginaire mais oui c'est sûr d'abord
parce que monsieur péladeau est connu à
l'extérieur du québec
c'est le propriétaire de sun news
c'était un allié
perçu de stephen harper et des
conservateurs pour ceux qui nous
écoutent sun youth est une chaîne de
nouvelles continues plus à droite plus à
droite mais il ya aussi tous les
journaux sun qui existe partout au
canada et particulièrement amicaux pour
le québec en passant mais donc on
connaît alors les patrons de presse je
vous dirai à l'extérieur du québec est
certainement probablement les lecteurs
se disent elle s'étend grosso los
errores que une personne d'affaires
connu au québec optent pour le camp
souverainiste comme monsieur péladeau
vient de le faire je pensais la première
fois que quelqu'un de cette envergure
dans les sacs d'affaires s'affiche comme
souvent on réveille en tout cas dans le
reste du canada mais j'allais dire le
réveil même ici parce que la question de
la souveraineté
michel ne devait pas être autant au
centre de ce début de campagne
électorale
on devait parler au contraire d'identité
avec la charte et pas de souveraineté
oui mais c'est jamais dans la nature du
pq de parler de souveraineté parce que
son collègue s'appelle le référendum et
si la souveraineté vu comme même par ses
adversaires quand quelque chose de
légitime de nobles le référendum il est
souvent vue comme la division la chicane
même dans les familles et tous là il ya
comme sur la table le référendum on a vu
monsieur couillard commencer dès ce
matin allez là dessus et ça va devenir
il est clair que ça va devenir un enjeu
est sûr c'est évident on va voir
d'ailleurs la publicité justement michel
que le parti libéral vient de faire
publier
c'est tout chaud donc voyez la photo de
pierre karl péladeau ya 15 à 10 1 juin
pays ce pour ces jo en politique
déterminée à briser un pays la 6e
libéraux québécois qui carrément vont
sur ce terrain là disent si notre
meilleur calcul d'un pensionnat vie
c'est leur meilleur est peut-être la
seule d'ailleurs parce que depuis la
campagne il ya vraiment que ça qui
mordent dans le discours libéral mais je
voudrais qu avant même l'arrivée de
monsieur péladeau depuis quelques jours
au pq on sent qu'un buzz référendaire
moi j'ai jamais sentie les péquistes
avoir autant envie de faire un
référendum que depuis l'élection 94 ma
foi
jeune candidat qui envoie des jeunes
candidats et les vieux qui se dit c'est
la dernière chance qu'on a alors je
pense que c'est beaucoup à ça qu'on
pense au pq quand on pense à péladeau
très bien ça c'est pour la campagne
électorale les questions de stratégie
les questions de souveraineté
il ya une question de conflits
d'intérêts potentiels qui ont été encore
une fois sur dix on en parlait hier
michel ensemble au téléjournal le fait
que monsieur péladeau et on leur ait
entendu aujourd'hui ne veut pas vendre
quebecor il est le propriétaire
actionnaire principal tour de table est
ce que c'est pas un problème potentiel
pour la perception de ce grand groupe de
presse là qui est québécois s'il est élu
si les ministres chantal d'abord ce sont
des films qui auraient dû être attachés
entre monsieur péladeau et madame marois
avant qu'il annonce sa candidature
ensuite l'idée qu'on va dire aux
québécois que le patron d'un empire
médiatique c'est comme quelqu'un qui
contrôle des bateaux c'est
malheureusement pas du tout la même
chose les mêmes vos actions dans un dans
un trust et dire c'est une fiducie sans
droit de regard mais ça vous empêche pas
de savoir comment l empire que vous
possédez beaucoup et de vous rappeler de
qui vous a recouvert comme c'est
vraiment difficile d'imaginer comment on
gère ce genre de choses là on parle pas
de tous les dossiers économiques dans
lesquels les intérêts de monsieur
péladeau en quelque chose à voir et donc
gouvernement du québec ce que parce
qu'on n'a pas de carte routière
c'est du jamais vu à ce niveau là dans
ce secteur d'activité la michel que vous
en pensez je pense que je ne comprends
pas la magnitude des conflits d'intérêts
qui pourraient dans lesquelles il
pourrait se trouver
il était mon émission tout à l'heure je
vais demander par exemple si on venait
avec la politique du prix unique du
livre
toute cette affaire mais vous êtes un
des plus gros libraire au québec est le
plus gros éditeur au québec avec richard
bobby des maisons d'édition vous avez
touché de vous retirer du conseil des
ministres c'est cela la politique des
conflits d'intérêts prévoit bien sûr que
non je suis une personne ressource non
sport comme ça que ça fonctionne et je
pense qu'ils n'avaient pas prévu au pq
que l'idée que monsieur péladeau reste
propriétaire de son empire est de la
traction dans l'opinion publique isidro
savoie intéressés savent intérêts
et puis on prend fin le 10 mars et la
fédération des journalistes mais ça a un
effet dans la clio publiquement nos
auditeurs aujourd'hui 30 % d'entre eux
disent que c'est ce qui les dérange
récurrent que madame marois avec son
mari toutes les activités de son mari
s'alarme continuellement alors imaginez
vous que monsieur péladeau il n'est pas
sorti du bois de ce côté là j'entendais
ou plutôt je lisais un communiqué de la
fédération des journalistes qu'ils
aiment super monsieur péladeau devra
donner des garanties mais quelle sorte
de garantie on peut donner la dendre a
beau mettre trois ceintures de le perdre
à bretelles il reste qu il y aura
toujours une connexion tellement
évidente entre la politique et les
normes monde des médias que ça va être
un confortable pour tout le monde donc
vous pensez vous je pense qu'ils vont
ils vont a décidé de vivre avec ça je
peux pas imaginer que monsieur péladeau
de sites de dix bons mais puisqu'on ne
veut pas que je garde mes actions je
quitte la politique je pense que nous y
vont ils vont essayer de gérer ça au
mieux mais ça serait pas sain d'être le
second de pauline marois quelqu'un
d'autre il va devoir penser à se
départir d'une partie de son empire
celui qui traite de contenu en
particulier tva les journaux autrement
ça va devenir maintenant il peut pas
vendre ses actions il y en a pour 1
milliard se trouve sur le coin de la vu
quelqu'un sait ce qu'il récupère la
douleur en plus je veux pas qu'on se
vendre à l'étranger jeuland orageuse
viennent donc ça va continuer ce
problème de conflit d'intérêts là il
faut qu'il se résolve n'ya pas beaucoup
de façons de résoudre entre on va
continuer à en parler
messieurs dames merci beaucoup d'être
venu nous voir on va se parler
vous êtes nos analyses donc maison on va
se retrouver ultime mans ensemble à la
soirée électorale
alors merci et à très bientôt chaque
vendredi on fait le point de la semaine
mais je pense est important aujourd'hui
de faire un point
merci vous